here we've got an area that we're gonna
it's an isolated area our house we've
decided to give kind of an English
garden appearance and so we've made the
decision to mow this grass significantly
lower less than two inches and then
around inch and a half two inch and 3/4
range now what that means is number one
you have to mow more frequently to not
violate the one-third rule and by not
violating the one-third rule means when
you know if you're keeping it an inch
and a half by the time it gets to about
two and a half inches
you have to mow it what that means you
got to get out here more often now first
thing second thing is you generally need
to specialized mower to mow lower so
that you're not stressing the plants and
here we've got a real mower
we've got a bad knife here where the
real meets the bad knife and I have to
regularly adjust the contact between the
real and the bed knife because you see
as the blade moves along it grabs the
grabs the grass blade and cuts it and
really gets a nice slice and this is
ideal for mowing closer now this happens
to be a motorized unit many people by
the hand operated real units and again
those are mostly designed to cut lower
now if you don't keep up on fertility
and other aspects of watering weed
control you get inundated with weeds
here because the turf is less
competitive we didn't select grasses
back here that tolerate close mowing we
just started mowing what was here now
we're slowly going to start introducing
grasses that are more low mowing
tolerant but right now we've just got
whatever was here and you can see the
weeds the dandelion and the clover
moving in so if we're going to want to
restore this to a more uniform
appearance and get rid of the weeds
we're gonna have to do something about
taking them out of there and again be
more judicious about the way we water
and fertilize
now the consequences of mowing low as
you can see here is that you get grease
on your hand